did you know a humanoid robot is granted
horn release citizenship in saudi arabia
also
the humanoid report market is estimated
to be worth
3.9 billion dollars by the year 2023.
the field of robotics is coming up with
many innovations and ideas with
every passing year we are currently
living in the 21st century
where technology is advancing at a
significantly faster
place the advancements made in the field
of artificial intelligence
and machine learning are tremendous and
astonishing
we are living in that era where we are
witnessing robots performing tasks
as human beings from assisting in
medical surgeries to handling various
tools
from cleaning utility holes to spot and
gas welding
robots are performing multiple tasks
reports are now deployed in numerous
industries for several jobs
they are accommodating in the areas
where the physical presence of a human
is dangerous robots are playing a
significant role in warfare and mining
nowadays
the best part is that unlike humans
they never get tired and hence in work
non-stop providing a 24-hour facility
some of the notable advancements in
artificial intelligence
and robotics are in healthcare civil
engineering
athletics art and entertainment
robots come in many different shapes and
sizes but perhaps
the most enduring and intriguing are the
ones that look
like humans over the years there are a
lot of humanoid reports being developed
by
various countries and organizations most
of them are used for personal assistance
education entertainment research
space exploration whereas others are
used for search and rescue operations
healthcare and public invasions
humanoid robots a humanoid report is the
one that resembles
us humans they have the body shape
and features similar to a human being
and are built
to mimic human interactions and motions
there is a rapid expansion of humanoid
robots in the market now
it's primarily due to the functions and
improved capabilities of these robots
many advanced humanoid robots are coming
up
every year that are capable of
performing individual tasks
let's quickly jump over and look at the
different advanced
humanoid robots developed by various
organizations
in the world walker the chinese company
ubitech robotics has developed an
intelligent humanoid service report
named walker ubitec's mission is to
introduce
intelligent robots into every home and
business
to make everyday life smarter and more
convenient
of late uvitech has made changes and
upgraded its humanoid robot
walker to make it more efficient this
humanoid report is capable of achieving
precise walking and stable movement in
all types of surfaces it's also capable
of the object
facial and environment recognition
talking about how we can communicate
with walker we can accomplish that via
text voice and facial expressions based
on programmed interaction
romeo 140 centimeters tall capable of
recognizing
faces walking and grasping objects
let's meet romeo who is designed to
assist people in their daily needs
weighing 36 to 40 kgs romeo will act as
a real companion
mainly helping the elderly in various
things
like making conversations suggesting
games
and playing with them this robot's
primary role is to help
people with everyday tasks like
remembering appointments
or the medication to be taken finding
lost spectacles
or compiling a shopping list ideally it
should also detect if the person has a
fall
and help them get up and call the
emergency services if required
the aldebaran team who is preparing
romeo to become the perfect companion
robot is also devoting their large part
of research
in teaching romeo how to cook pancakes
by following a recipe it will download
from the internet
in the future romeo will join a long
line of advanced humanoid robots
that are intended to entertain and help
care
zenbo zenbo is a new robot trend for
kids
seniors and anybody else who would love
to have a smart little companion with
them
this robot stands about knee height when
compared to an
average adult zenbook as a security
guard
smart home manager hands-free kitchen
assistant
friendly companion and a family
photographer as well
in response to voice queries zenbo gives
recommendations like
recipe recommendations and similar
services
he can buy goods online by logging into
your account
and inputting passwords by your voice
assistants
he would also take photos like an
autonomous selfie stick
asus who developed zenboo has emphasized
the robot's
usefulness for older people as well this
robot can also sing
songs tell stories dance to music
and even work as a tutor to the children
zenbo will cost 5.99
if you want to purchase it for your home
hrb 5b
targeting rnd platforms hr p5p is a
humanoid robot designed for its
practical use
at sites for assembling large structures
it's mainly used at construction sites
shipyards
and eight crack facilities it's designed
with a high power body with improved
robot intelligence
like object recognition and
environmental measurement
hrp5p is centimeter
and 101 kg robot with a total of 37
degrees of freedom
it's built by incorporating new hardware
technologies
and is capable of handling screwdrivers
and installing drywalls
this robot is being developed by aist
japan's national institute of advanced
industrial science
and technology the main aim of creating
this report is to replace
heavy duty human labor in response to
the country's changing demographics
with the controlled birth rate heavy
human labor is a rising problem in japan
with robots like this that would not be
a problem anymore
in the future if everything goes
according to the plan of
aisd we might see all the drywalls being
handled by hrb5p robots
pigeon say hello to digit a humanoid
report designed to move more dynamically
compared to regular robots
this 155 centimeter report weighing 42.2
kilogram
was developed in 2019 by agility
robotics
digit is strong enough to pick up and
stack boxes
which are up to 18 kg ford is teaming up
with
agility robotics to bring about a change
in the delivery services
this robot could change the way
self-driving cars make deliveries
it can tightly fold itself up until it's
called into action
making it convenient for storage at the
back of self-driving vehicles
it can walk naturally through uneven
terrain go
up and down the stairs and even react to
being bummed without losing the balance
digit can be deployed to carry out the
entire delivery process
from grabbing a package from the vehicle
to carrying out the final two-step
delivery
ford and agility robotics are closely
working
to determine the best way out for
self-driving vehicles to cooperate
with this report and establish the new
delivery method in the future
spot mini this 84 centimeter robot
developed by
boston dynamics is capable of climbing
stairs and handling objects
it weighs 30 kg and operates in homes
offices and outdoors this four-legged
smallest dog robot has various cameras
inbuilt in its mainframe
it also has an optional snake-like arm
that
allows it to do tasks like opening doors
this optional arm gets attached where a
real dog's head would be
it's five degrees of freedom arm
movement
can fetch you a glass of your favorite
drink without breaking it
atlas developed by the american robotics
company
boston dynamics atlas is a bipedal
humanoid robot
designed for various search and rescue
tasks
it is a 1.8 meter robot created in 2013.
this robot is mainly intended to aid
emergency
services performing tasks like opening
doors shutting off valves and operating
powered equipment with the stuff for
humans to survive
atlas weighs 80 kg and has one of the
world's most compact mobile hydraulic
systems
it has 28 joints and moves at a speed of
1.5 meter per second
it is designed to operate both outdoors
and
indoors it has 28 degrees of freedom
which allows it to drive a utility
vehicle at the site
open a door and enter a building
atlas also removes any dead dress
present that blocks an entryway
locates and closes a valve near a
leaking pipe
pepper meat pepper the world's first
social humanoid robot capable of
recognizing faces and basic
human emotions it was optimized for
human interaction and can engage with
people
through various conversations and his
top screen
around the globe over 2000 companies
have adopted pepper
as an assistant for various tasks like
welcoming and guiding the visitors in a
very innovative way
pepper has 20 degrees of freedom and is
capable of speech recognition
in 15 different languages
it stands 120 centimeters tall with a
touchscreen on his chest
displaying content to highlight messages
and support speech
his curvy design makes him cute and
ensures
danger free use pepper was manufactured
by
softbank robotics and was introduced in
a conference
on june 5th 2014.
currently he is being used at banks
and medical facilities in japan and as
a receptionist at several uk offices
pepper was also reported to have been
used in several homes in japan
being available as a research and
educational robot
pepper teaches programming at several
schools and colleges
unlike zenbo pepper is not a functional
report for domestic use
pepper has two hd cameras a 3d
depth sensor and four microphones in his
head
he weighs 28 kilograms and runs on
lithium-ion batteries
his creators hope that new uses and
content will be created for pepper
from his independent developers in the
future
sophia remember we mentioned a robot who
was granted hundred
citizenship in country meet sophia a
saudi arabian citizen
the first report to receive citizenship
in any country
she is a social humanoid robot who made
her first public appearance
in march 2016 in texas
united states she was developed by a
hong kong-based company
called hansen robotics she's been
covered by
various media around the globe and has
participated
in several high-profile interviews
sophia was given citizenship in october
2017
and is the first non-human to be given
any united nations title
she can recognize faces sustain eye
contact
process speech and converse using
natural language processing
standing 167 centimeter long
and weighing 20 kg sophia is designed
for
education research entertainment
and for promoting public discussions
about the future of robotics and ai
ethics
she has met numerous celebrities
including jimmy fallon and will smith
and has traveled to over 25 countries
until now
sophia and her designers dream of that
future
where humans and ai live
and work together in friendship and
symbiosis to make this world a better
place
similarly various other humanoid and
half humanoid robots are being developed
developed for stunts this tantronic
robot combines advanced robotic
technology
with untethered dynamic movement it
performs twists
aerial flips and poses with
repeatability
and precision this robot is 175
centimeter long increase 40 kg
aquanaut aquanaut is an underwater
vehicle that transforms itself
into a half humanoid robot from a nimble
submarine
designed for long distance cruising
developed by
houston mechatronics inc this
half-humanoid robot can perform complex
manipulation tasks
it stands 97 centimeter long and weighs
1050 kg moving at a speed
of 13 kilometer per hour
mitra a friendly neighborhood report
that came into limelight when the indian
prime minister narendra modi
and the advisor to the president of the
united states
ivanka trump opened the ges session in
hyderabad
mitra created by inventor robotics is
white in color and has a face
that could perfectly fit any sci-fi book
undoubtedly the robotics field will
reach greater heights in the future
with many more advancements and more
efficient reports
the ways in which these humanoid robots
are deployed are continually expanding
looking at all these innovative robots
we would
definitely wish to have a dream reward
for ourselves
that can perform most of our daily
routine tasks and
automate our lives at times when we are
lazy
when we are tired and exhausted we wish
for a robot companion to come to our
rescue
a robot like buddy portraying emotions
and acting as a perfect playmate
and a report similar to romeo who would
assist me in my
everyday tasks and reminds me of my
schedule
and meetings with the functionalities of
a robot like
zenbo who would sing songs and dance
with me when i need a partner
and look after my home when i'm not
there a report-like digit
which can fetch me my boxes and things
from other places when i'm lazy
a stuntronic robot who can act as my
personal bodyguard
and protect me by performing stunts
against the evil people
my dream report would definitely be a
blend of these robots
and i would call her my claudia
she will be the closest one to me in all
my things and deeds
she would be excited when i am excited
and happy
she would console me when i'm sad cook
food for me when i return home from my
office
exhausted everyone has their own dream
robot
and mine would definitely be claudia my
best friend to whom i would be
emotionally
attached to what kind of a report is
your dream report
let us know in the comment section below